in our explorations of different sufi
orders we have primarily so far stayed
in the east the nakshbandi and the
imatulahi orders both being from the
central asian region
now today we're going to turn our gaze
to north africa to explore one of the
most influential sufi orders in history
the shatterly order
the chavulia as it's also known is the
most widespread order in north africa
both today and for most of history and
it has also attracted a lot of people
from europe and north america in the
last century it's a sufi order that is
often known as one that adheres very
strictly to islamic law and that seems
to attract people in particular or very
high intellectual status or scholars
basically why is this are these claims
even true and what is the history and
development of the shadowly order as
well as the role that it plays in the
world today
[Music]
the story about the origins of the
shadolia is essentially also the story
about the beginnings of tariqah sufism
in the maghrib which is western north
africa tariqah is the arabic word for
path which refers to an order in the
sufi tradition
and these orders started to develop
first in the 12th and 13th centuries
primarily in these central islamic
regions like modern iraq and syria
at this time the earliest orders of
sufism like the khadiriya the urephaya
and the suravardia had already started
to develop in these central regions
in north africa this more
institutionalized form of sufism hadn't
really entered the picture yet
there were so-called ribats or convents
of sorts to which certain sufis would be
connected but these did not constitute a
formal path or organized practice in the
same way that the eastern tariqas did
the word tariqa wasn't used in the
context of the maghrib which includes
countries like morocco algeria and
tunisia or in al-andalus southern spain
instead the few organized forms of
renunciant practices or sufism broadly
defined were called ta'ifa meaning
something like a fellowship or community
the early ta'ifas however were often
connected to berber tribal identity
membership essentially was only allowed
to and revolved around being part of a
specific tribe and not common practice
in the way of the eastern orders sufism
in the maghrib and al-andalus revolved
more around individual renuncians and
mystics and their saintly authority
north african sufism as such had very
unique characteristics that differ them
somewhat from the sufism in the lands of
the east
some of the literature associated with
the baghdad sufis such as works by al
mahasibhi nuri and others had of course
penetrated into the western regions and
influenced various renunciants here but
by and large maghribi and andalusian
sufism developed on a trajectory of its
own with its own unique practices ideas
and modes of authority this authority
was not only based on things like deep
mystical insight and experiences but a
huge emphasis was put on altruism so the
sufi saints ability to
love his neighbor to give to the poor
and to act selflessly give to those who
are in need and being a caring person
often to the detriment of themselves and
there's perhaps no better example of
this in the early period than the figure
abu labas a sabti who is considered the
sort of patron saint of marrakesh
while in eastern sufism more emphasis
was put on psychology so the inner
states and stations of the sufi path
which would be traversed by the
practitioner in the western context well
this isn't completely absent of course
authority and emphasis was more put on
outer expressions of this piety like the
aforementioned altruism and charity
among other things
we also see in al andalus and the
maghrib a more philosophically or
theoretically oriented mysticism
concerned with metaphysical speculation
and theories which was represented by
figures like ibn masara ibn barajan and
which would culminate later with figures
like ibn arabi and even sabain
indeed it is in the 12th century that
sufism really starts to gain some steam
in the maghreb and in which we find some
of the most foundational figures like
ali ibn hirsihim of fez
the very charismatic wandering berber
mystic abu yazah and the ecstatic and
controversial abu abdullah
as well as their collective student and
perhaps the most significant sufi
personality at this time abu madian
these are all important characters in
our story today as they provide the
background and context for our narrative
but they are not our main characters the
shadowly order is based on the life and
teachings of another sufi saint abu
hassan ashad
he was born in northern morocco at the
end of the 12th century and is together
with his predecessor abu madiyan largely
responsible for bringing together the
native sufi traditions in the maghrib
with the established forms of sufism in
the east represented by figures like
al-ghazali
the order that was founded based on him
would also be the first time that the
sufi order in the international
institutionalized sense firmly enter the
western lands of the islamic world
the life of a shadowy is as is almost
always the case difficult to tell with
certainty as we are working with a
number of different hagiographical
material that sometimes even contradict
each other he was an arab in terms of
ethnicity and even a sharif a descendant
of the prophet muhammad which already
was a sign of great authority in this
region at the time
it seems that early in his life he
studied in fez which was the kind of
intellectual and religious spiritual
capital of morocco at this time the
biographical accounts tell us that he
was a kind of spiritual seeker who was
looking for a sufi master to study under
and it is for this reason that it seems
that in 1223 he traveled eastward to
egypt and possibly iraq to find this
master to whom he could become a student
here he met a master of the refi sufi
order called abulfat al-waasiti and
briefly became his disciple however this
sheikh told ashadhali that he was to
travel back to the maghrib to find his
true spiritual guide there so once back
in his home region a shadowly went
looking for this master and finally in a
small hermitage on top of a mountain in
morocco called jabal alam he found him
in the person of abdul-salam ibn mashish
a charismatic and aesthetical hermit
ibn mashish would be the most important
figure in ashath's life and the one that
opened the doors to spiritual awakening
for him as it were
also known locally as molay abdul salaam
he is considered a kind of patron saint
for all of morocco to this day after
having been initiated by his new master
a shadoli then settled for a while in
what is today tunisia in a village close
to tunis called chadila which is where
he eventually got his name
he became quite a popular preacher and
sufi personality here and attracted a
large group of followers but also
aroused the suspicion of the local
al-muhad authorities he was accused as
is often the case of being a shiite
agitator among other things and after a
while decided to travel east again
primarily he went on the hajj or
pilgrimage to mecca and then settled
eventually in alexandria in egypt
here he continued to be very popular was
supported by the authorities and amassed
an increasing group of disciples he
would perform the pilgrimage once every
year for the rest of his life but it was
on one of these pilgrimages in 1258 that
he passed away in the egyptian village
of humaithara where he was buried and
his shrine still stands today ashadi was
a prolific and charismatic teacher but
he didn't really produce anything in
terms of written material for us to
study
there is a very popular prayer that is
attributed to him that is known as the
hispal bahr or the litany of the sea but
not much other than this at all his
authority basically rested entirely on
his charisma and his skill as a teacher
and spiritual guide and it was up to his
successors to formulate those teachings
into a proper sufi order his first
successor as leader for the community
was abu labas al-mursi who had
accompanied the master from tunis to
egypt
but probably the most significant was
the second successor ibn attah allah
al-askandari
he was a native of alexandria who had
become attracted to the teachings of
ashadhali through al-mursi and is
probably most responsible for turning
the shadolia into a proper sufi tariqa
unlike ashavali and al-mursi ibn at
allah was a prolific writer and scholar
he firstly wrote a biography of abul
hassana shadoli in which he places him
within a more eastern paradigm of
spiritual authority names him the
spiritual pole of the age and thus lay
the groundwork for what would become one
of the most widespread sufi orders in
the world
perhaps most famously he composed the
kitab al-hikham the book of wisdoms
which is a book of short beautiful
aphorisms that has become immensely
popular and influential in the shadily
border and beyond ibn allah is also a
kind of defender of sufi practices and
ideas against its enemies most notably
he engaged in debates with the renowned
scholar and critic ibn taymiyah you
could say that the shadolia developed in
two different directions at this point
one led by ibn ta'ala where it's based
in egypt and alexandria which eventually
became the dominant but also another
kind of branch in western north africa
in the maghreb which accepted another
succession of leaders after abu labas
al-mursi there could be differences in
practice and things like this between
the two groups but you could argue that
eventually over the centuries the two
kind of merged to the point that the
chavelia as a
sort of
as a single order became the dominant
sufi tariqa in all of north africa even
to the point that many established sufi
movements at the time like the school of
the sufi philosopher ibn sabahin and his
student ashushtari became essentially
absorbed into the shadowy order
important for the development of the
order into dominance in the region are
also later developments and further
branches of the order particularly the
teachings and movement of muhammad
al-jazeera a shadowly master whose
branch is often called the chad lia
jazuliyah or simply jasolia and which
created a form of sufism that was
heavily involved in the politics of the
region and the development of sharifism
the idea that political and religious
authority was primarily the privileged
right of the descendants of the prophet
muhammad which has heavily shaped
morocco to this day
al-jazeera lee wrote the very popular
prayer book called dalai ilharat which
is specifically dedicated to prayers and
supplications for the prophet muhammad
indeed jesus and his followers would
place an enormous emphasis on the role
of the prophet and his role in the
spiritual quest even more so than other
sufi movements which is really saying
something according to jamal abu nasser
the dalai lama made veneration of the
prophet the core of sufi piety the
jesuit movement became so popular that
it solidified the shadowly order as the
most dominant in the maghrib and
reshaped the region's entire spiritual
and religious landscape
the heavy emphasis on venerating the
prophet muhammad would become an
important feature of moroccan sufism in
particular and later referred to as the
tariqa muhammadiyah
if you read sufi poetry from this region
from the last few hundred years there is
an unusually strong focus on praising
the prophets and this also explains the
connection with the political ideas of
sharifism
in general the particular teachings and
practices of the chattalia are difficult
to talk about because just like other
orders like the kadaria the shadolis
have never had a single head of
authority and neither did the early
leaders of the community establish any
particular rules or way of doing things
we can play it safe by saying that the
shadily order practiced the most
universal sufi ritual known as thikr or
remembrance where names of god or the
muslim proclamation of faith is repeated
for long periods of time one will often
have regular gatherings called hadra in
which practices like these are performed
and as with all other orders the
shadolis have their own weird or prayers
and prayer cycles that are given to
initiates by their sheikh and which are
recited either privately and in or in
group
allah in fact did write a treatise
dedicated to vikkit in particular called
miftah falah the key to salvation in
which he defends the practice as well as
its vocal performance in particular so
that is the
vocal chanting of vikkan that is perhaps
the most common in sufism where people
will sit in groups and will they will
chant vocally sometimes pretty loudly
the names of god or the proclamation of
faith some
other muslims and even sufi muslims were
against this idea of doing it vocally
but most weren't and ibna ta'ala writes
this treatise
where he among other things defends this
uh vocal practice of thicker so we know
that the shadows even in the early
periods did perform thicker and that
they did so vocally but other than these
basic practices there is really not much
that characterizes the chadelia in
particular
and because it has spread so widely
across north africa as well as the rest
of the world we see a lot of variety and
diversity between regions and branches
of the order so it's difficult to say
something in particular
that characterizes the order in general
just as in many other sufi traditions
the shadolist view as important the
visiting or ziara to the shrine of
ashadhi where he is buried which is in
humaith egypt as i mentioned and they
will often gather there annually usually
on his birthday or maulid going to this
one village in in egypt and they will do
vikker or vocal chanting together
sometimes sing with percussion
instruments they will pray together and
other
rituals related to the shadowly
practices the shadowly order is often
described as a sober sufi order what
this means is that they usually don't
take part in more ecstatic practices
such as the elaborate sama
rituals or music rituals of other orders
like the mev levia for example with the
very famous whirling dervishes related
to this it is also claimed that the
chavelia is a sufi order that adheres
very strictly to islamic law now i would
be very careful about claims like this
because basically all sufi orders very
strictly follow islamic law at least as
they understand it but this means that
just like all other muslims the
shadolists pray five times a day they do
the hajj to mecca they give to charity
and all the other obligations that other
muslims follow aside from their
supergatory and additional prayers and
practices that they do as part of the
sufi way so to say i think what is
usually meant with this following
islamic law strictly thing is the
previous point about the order being
more sober quote unquote which is a
accurate enough claim i guess i think it
might also have something to do with the
fact that
as i said earlier there isn't a lot that
characterizes the the chandelier in
particular like many other sufj orders
for example if we talk about the mev
levy order like if you ask me to
describe the medley order there are like
clear characteristics like all the
whirling dervishes the elaborate sama
rituals uh if you ask me to describe the
chishtia order always the the kawali
music and these sama practices there
okay if you ask me to to talk about the
defy order well they have the very
elaborate sort of rituals involving
swords and like and when we talk about
the shadowy order it's like
they're muslims like there isn't
anything that stands out in the same way
about the chandelier in comparison to
many other orders around the world i
think that's why some may feel that the
shadowy order is more in in line with
islamic law they seem more like regular
muslims and all this is very problematic
of course but
if i had to guess i think it has
something to do with that too but like i
said because of the lack of any distinct
rules within the order and it's
widespread there is huge diversity
within the shadowly order some branches
are very politically unsocially active
others are more quietest some branches
practice sama or ritualize listening to
music others don't and so on
over the centuries the chavelia has
developed several sub-branches all with
characteristic features and practices of
their own one of the most significant of
these branches has been the shadolia
darakawiya founded by the moroccan
muhammad al-arabi al-darkawi
this branch is sometimes characterized
by a doctrinal adherence to the school
of the andalusian master ibn arabi and
his ideas of the unity of being as can
be seen from the writings of darakawi
masters like ahmed ibn ajiba
but it has also become probably the most
widespread globally and attracted many
westerners in particular
one figure from the darakawi linear that
has become especially formative in this
later regard is the algerian ahmed
al-alawi on which there is an amazing
book called a sufi saint of the 20th
century by the author martin lings
indeed as many westerners started to
become interested in sufism and islam
around the turn of the 20th century it
was often to the shadowly order in
particular that they turned the swedish
painter ivan aguili is probably the
first of these converts he had a special
fascination with the teachings of ibn
arabi and joined the shadily order while
living in egypt
aguili was the person who in turn
initiated the famous rene guenon and
here we see the start of the so-called
traditionalist school or the school of
perennial philosophy
this is a movement that has emerged in
the last century that emphasizes a
perennial wisdom that hides within all
of the world's quote-unquote true
religions often with the view that sufi
oriented islam is the most complete
expression of this perennial wisdom the
representatives of this school are often
followers of ahmed al-alawi in
particular who kind of created a branch
of his own within the shadolia darqawiya
which is often called the chavelia
alawia now these branches and super
branches often get very complicated and
complex but stay with me here in a case
this perennial school often associated
with the shadily order in particular has
been represented by figures like the
already mentioned rene guenon fritschev
shuwon martin lynx and the current most
prominent teacher and philosopher syed
jose nasser
this group of scholars have also been
instrumental in bringing the work of
many sufi scholars of history to a
western audience such as many
translations and interpretations of
figures like ibn arabi and mulasadra and
they do shape our understanding of these
figures to a massive degree but not all
prominent shadily figures in the west
are connected to the traditionalist
school or the alawia the american
islamic scholar no hameem keller is also
an adherent of the shadoli darqawi order
and is often considered one of the most
important muslim teachers in the world
today through his many publications and
commitment to online education we should
also mention the recently passed
american sufi nourodin durki may he rest
in peace who further spread the order to
the u.s and very interestingly also has
connections to other contemporary
figures like ramdas and was actually
largely responsible in his youth for the
publication of his very popular work
called be here now
it is because of the popularity of the
shadolia among scholars and western
converts of high intellectual status
that the shadowy order has become famous
as an order that in particular seems to
attract people of very high education or
intellectual prominence or whatever you
want to call it
it's hard to say why this is or if this
is even accurate to begin with but it
might have something to do with the
so-called sober approach of the order as
well as the flexibility that it has
because it has become so widespread and
that it doesn't have any particularly
fixed rules and so on
that's one guess as to why it has
attracted so many from the west more so
perhaps i would argue that it has
something to do with the historical
circumstances in which this order was
accessible to the figures of the early
20th century so as you can tell the
chavalia is a sufi order that has not
only managed to survive almost 900 years
but has also spread to places all across
the world
the community started by abul hasan
ashavi in the 13th century has become a
decisive factor in the history of north
african sufism through his incorporation
of local maghrib slash and lucian sufi
traditions with the tariqa based sufism
of the east and the later firm
establishment of his authority into an
institutionalized tariqa by successors
like ibn
the shadowy order brought a slightly new
kind of islamic mysticism to the western
lands of the islamic world
ashadhali stands together with abu
madyan as perhaps the most important
figures in the western sufi tradition
and the order that was founded based on
him came to dominate this region for the
rest of history later developments in
the order further shaped the political
and religious landscape of the maghreb
and lately has also come to shape the
religious landscape of europe and north
america so the shadily order is not only
one of the oldest surviving sufi orders
in history it is also absolutely one of
the most important
i'll see you next time
i would like to express my deepest
gratitude to all of my patrons who keep
this channel going through their support
and as always a special shout out to all
of my new saints including nicholas cano
prophet's apprentice
rodenborn and abbas akbar thank you all
so much
[Music]
you